"TEXT FROM YOUR PARENTS."
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
IT'S A BAD DAY WHEN YOUR PARENTS
LEARN HOW TO TEXT.
MY DAD JUST LEARNED HOW TO TEXT
LIKE A YEAR AGO.
AND IT WASN'T EVEN THAT THERE
WERE TYPOS.
LIKE HIS GRAMMAR, I WOULD GET
THESE TEXTS LIKE, "ME SORRY, ME
DO BETTER."
"ME DO BETTER!"
LIKE WE GAVE A SMART PHONE TO A
CHIMP AND JUST LET HIM KIND OF
LIKE...
"ME DO BETTER."
(LAUGHTER)
ALL RIGHT, SO COMEDIANS, PLEASE
GIVE ME AS MANY PARENT TEXTS AS
YOU CAN.
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK AND GO.
YES, DANA.
>> HEY, MOM'S DEAD.
J.K., SUP DOG?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
ARDEN.
>> JUSTIN BIEBER IS LIQUID GOLD.
REAL ONE FROM MY MOM.
>> Chris: POINTS!
TO YOU AND YOUR MOM.
NICK.
>> WHAT WAS THE NAME OF YOUR
FRIEND FROM HIGH SCHOOL?
I THOUGHT I SAW HIS MOM.
BUT IT WASN'T.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
ARDEN.
>> GREAT NEWS!
WE'RE COMING WITH YOU TO
COACHELLA.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: OH, WAY POINTS.
NICK.
>> TWO AND A HALF MEN-- SO
FUNNY, HAVE YOU SEEN?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
POINTS.
DANA.
>> HEY, "SON," GUESS WHO HAD A
BLOOD TEST?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS!
ARDEN.
>> TURNED YOUR ROOM INTO AIRBNB,
GOT FELT UP BY THE NICEST
FRENCHMAN.
>> Chris: POINTS!
NICK.
>> CHRIS HARDWICK, SO FUNNY,
HAVE YOU MET?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: WAIT, I'M IN THE SAME
CATEGORY AS TWO AND A HALF MEN?
ALL RIGHT, I'LL TAKE IT.
POINTS.
DANA.
>> THEY ARRESTED FATHER DONEGAN.
WILL YOU COME BACK TO THE CHURCH
NOW?
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)